Lee: Korean water is very dark and very cold.
People don't usually dive there for fun, but that's what I do.
Today's water is calm
and we're going to do a wreck dive.
It looks so dangerous
but when your eyes become accustomed to the environment
and you realize that things are moving,
It's great to watch them.
I saw a fish - so big - and it's absolutely incredible.
Then I get very good
what I never expected there,
such as instant coffee cups, stickers.
It's disturbing.
We must think about conserving the ocean.
Diving into the water completely releases me
of the world in which I live;
with 20 million people living in and around the city.
This again gives me a sense of connection with nature.